Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full House of the Dragon episode 4 video there
were a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes I'll be doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did for the original Game of Thrones
series so careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet starting at the beginning of
the episode and working our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
starting with the title of the episode King of
the narrow sea which is a reference to Daemon
targaryen's title that his men call him after
they name him King of the step stones after they
defeat the triarchy and crap feeder the only big
change that I could see in the opening title
scene which is the addition of another stream
of blood coming from Alicent Hightower symbol to
represent the birth of both of her children with
viserys Helaena Targaryen is the second child you
see her trying to comfort her later in the episode
Rhaenyra is fortunate that there's only like two
other people contending for the Iron Throne right
now even though nobody is really thinking about
Daemon being a potential Contender at the moment
the actual opening scene is inside Storm's end
this is the first time I believe we've been inside
the castle we we saw the castle during the Game of
Thrones episodes but we never actually went inside
she's with Borman Baratheon he's the head of
their household he's the one that swore the oath
of fealty to her and they're listening to a bunch
of suitors it's this big marriage tour that her
father viserys and alicent set up for her because
they want to find her husband and about a year has
gone by so the whole idea is that even though she
cuts her to her short and they're really pissed
off about that it had been going on for a long
time already the first person she's listening to
in the episode begins is Barrick dandarian that
will remind you of berrick dondarrion later in
the timeline from the events of Game of Thrones
with the Flaming sword the blackhaven castle he's
talking about is their main seat of power and
that's the place where Criston Cole came from
basically he was born the son of the steward to
Lord Dondarrion at the time so they really want to
start foreshadowing all this Criston Cole Rhaenyra
drama early in the episode don't worry I'll get to
that too because they kind of soft confirmed a
huge rumor from the books but there was a huge
twist in the interpretation of the rumor like
the truth of the rumor was a big twist when
he mentions Queen alisan her great grandmother or
that was J Harris's wife they referenced J Harris
a couple times in the episode in visares basically
tells her if you'd have been J Harris's daughter
he would have disinherited you which is another
huge deep cut from the books because that actually
did happen to one of Jay Harris's daughters he
had many children and all them met very untimely
or very weird Fates which is why things got so
bad with the succession during his Reign that
they had to call that great Council of 101 AC
one of his daughters named Sarah got involved
in a scandal involving flea bottom very similar to
what happened to rhaenyra in this episode and she
basically fled to the East and he disinherited her
but big connection to episode 1 Sarah eventually
followed a bastard child who had a claim to the
Iron Throne like a very loose claim but a claimed
nonetheless so in episode one when they said
14 claims were heard during the Great Council
of 101 AC one of those claims was from Sarah's
bastard one of The Heirs of house Bracken insults
the blackhaven air they have a small fight and he
winds up killing him and it's just meant to show
you some of the chaos that's going on in the realm
because of the issue of her Bridge setting up the
whole idea by the end of the episode that viserys
has all these problems that he eventually tries
to solve with one fell blow like okay we'll solve
all these problems and you just wind up marrying
corlys velaryon's son laenor velaryon here no
more spicy gossip about what you might be up to
in flea bottom with your uncle or anyone else and
because you'll be claimed by another Lord none of
the other Lords of the realm will have any reason
to start any Civil Wars over your hand there are a
lot of references to that in the episode too like
them trying to avert a civil war like they're all
these things that happen Daemon even asking for
Rhaenyra's hand emissaria kind of throwing them
under the bus to try and save Daemon from himself
I'll talk about that in a second too because it
was Mysaria going full Varys Varys was Master of
whisper so he did all kinds of shady stuff he had
his little birds all over the place massary is
kind of filling that role on the show right now
like she has all these little birds informing her
on everything and she's trying to help Daemon in
spite of himself but as they sail back to the red
keep you notice they have a very Targaryen themed
ship like all these Dragon designs all all over
it Daemon does a flyby on caraxes mostly just
to say hello lucky just kind of messing with her
a little bit on his way to Swagger back into the
Iron Throne Room the whole court is there to watch
him do his little victory dance corlys' velaryon's
men named him King of the narrow Sea King of the
stepstones technically it's not part of Westeros
so that's why he can do that the actual crown
looks like it's made from the bones of either
dead triarchy or possibly crabfeeder's bones
like they look like human bones he also throws
down crabfeeder's Hammer at his brother's feet so
it's like his little victory dance in front of the
entire court like all the Lords of the realm or
watching this happen so is him working his way
back into his brother's Graces I love the scene of
them as brothers in the godswood too like they're
standing underneath the weirwood and viserys is
telling alicent all these stories about he and
his brother when they were younger and how his
mother loved Daemon way more because he was just
so much more of a badass than he was and when he's
talking about how Daemon doesn't love tradition he
doesn't care about ceremony or anything like that
it just meant to juxtapose the role of male heirs
versus female heirs as he tells Rhaenyra at the
end of the episode like yes have you were born a
male Heir the realm wouldn't really care what you
get up to in flea bottom but because you were born
a female there are way greater consequences in
the realm's eyes and it doesn't matter what she
actually does it just matters what they perceive
that she did it looks like in the intervening year
at least before all the drama happens later
in the episode she and alicent have kind of
made up a little bit she's wearing a red and
black Targaryen themed dress which is a bit
different like people wonder when she's going to
start wearing different clothing because usually
you think of alicent you think of the greens
like she usually wears a green color for their
household and because she was so Infamous for
wearing green gowns why they call her side in
the Targaryen Civil War the greens it also kind
of seems like Alison has started to resent her
role in the grand scheme of things like she feels
kind of like she's a trophy wife she only exists
to birth more potential heirs for viserys which
they juxtapose with a very very spicy scenes later
in the episode like two different spicy scenes but
one is like the most unsexy version of that scene
and the other is like the most spicy version of
that scene just to show you what things are like
like for her day to day like she just kind of
like this person that people take for granted
they had that little scene with Daemon Rhaenyra
speaking High Valyrian to each other is sort of
like their own secret language that they speak but
all targaryens in the family in the Royal line of
succession here they all speak high valyrian so
if viserys were standing there he would be able to
speak high valyrian with them too because she's
of age now things are way spicier between them
like there was a little weirdness between the two
of them in episode one but I believe she's meant
to be about 12 years younger than Daemon so in
episode one Daemon even though he was having a
little bit of fun with her like they are clearly
very close he wasn't going to take things in that
direction he wasn't really thinking about an
actual marriage to her or anything like that at
the time but now clearly that has changed that's
also why he touches the valyrian necklace that
he gave her they also let you know what things
are like for him day to day too like you get a
little bit inside his head he still hates being
married to his wife in The Veil Ria Roy's even
though she's meant to be like a fairly normal
person like she's not bad or anything like that
he just hates the idea that he was forced to
marry her he gives her a little bit of a pep
talk like marriage isn't so bad and you can pretty
much do whatever you want anyway even if you are
buried setting up the later parts of the episode
where they do get really spicy the whole scene of
the small Council discussing the Fallout between
house velaryon and the crown is just meant to set
at the end of the episode like okay we need to
solve all these problems we have a very clear
solution here you will marry laenor velaryon
and we will solve all these in one Fell Swoop
Otto Hightower also briefly mentions the Sea
Lord of braavos reminding us of all the Arya
and Bravo scenes during the Game of Thrones series
we haven't actually traveled to the east like the
stepstones is the furthest East we've been so
far so we'll see if we actually go to the east
at any point during the series then we see that
Daemon has sent Rhaenyra commoners close in the
secret Escape Route using the Valyrian language
like it's the written valyrian language to help
her get out of the red keep in the secret passages
undetected I don't think that we've actually seen
these secret passages in the red keep before they
take her past the monument to valyrian the black
dread and he takes her out for a bit of fun in
flea bottom you also notice as they're leaving
the red keep in the distance you can see the
dragon pit I think that's a reference to what
happens later in the episode with Daemon talking
to her about ignore touring the commoner's wishes
at her own Peril like you need to pay attention
to what the commoners the small folk think about
you because they could bite you in the ass big
time later I don't want to talk too far ahead
of the story because a lot of the stuff that they
referenced in the episode they'll pay off any of
their future Seasons maybe a little bit later
this season but mostly future Seasons but at
least at this point in the timeline it seems like
she could care less about the wishes of the small
folk and that's a big big deal another funny
detail here too like they spent all this time
in flea bottom Daemon's other nickname is the Lord
of flea bottom because he spends so much time here
like all the spicy stuff that they get up to here
it's just like a regular Monday night for Daemon
they pass the witch on the street that says that
she'll tell renera how she dies no spoilers for
the books but like that is played out of the
books you could actually go read that there's
even an episode during Game of Thrones season four
I believe where Joffrey references what happened
to renera so if you have read the books or you do
remember that scene from Game of Thrones please
don't post that spoiler in the comments below
but the scene is also meant to be a reference
to the Maggie the Frog prophecy scene where Cersei
went to learn her future from Maggy the Frog even
though Rhaenyra doesn't get her future told here
the prophecy that Cersei got did wind up coming
true in a very twisty very WTF kind of way then
we see viserys declining Health in the intervening
year since last week's episode he has lesions all
over his body now they show his missing digits he
may have lost a couple other digits on his toes
too and it kind of seems like he's in a constant
state of dull pain like his drink there might be
a little bit milk of the poppy when we go back
to flea bottom the play that they're watching
on the street is meant to be a mirror of arya's
play that was called the bloody hand meant to be
commentary on the plot of the series and in this
case they're doing the same thing but it's all
about the succession in the Iron Throne who will
it be will it be Daemon the brother will it be
the daughter Rhaenyra or the princeling of three
which is aegon II with Rhaenyra just having to sit
there and listen to them clown on her remember the
big deal here is the demons like you need to chill
out and just listen to what the rest of the common
folk think this is also meant to show you that
Daemon actually does care about what the small
folk think like he does want to help the people
of King's Landing even though in episode 1 they
wanted to make him seem like more of a tyrant
which is obviously a bit of a misdirect like he
actually does care about people when she runs off
because she doesn't have any money she bumps into
Harwin Strong which is meant to be a big reference
to the joke about the strong boys because if you
notice in the trailers her first two sons are both
pruned as so there's this nasty rumor that goes
around the realm that her sons really belong to
Harwin Strong and they call them the strong boys
instead of being laenor velaryon's sons because
he has silver hair just like she does it'll give
you big flashbacks to Game of Thrones season one
the seed is strong like why don't any of Robert
baratheon's children have brown hair like his oh
because they're not Robert baratheon's children
we have our maximum spy scene with Daemon and
Rhaenyra where he basically stops things before
they get too crazy I think what's going on here
is that he does love the chaos just a little bit
like there's a little bit of that little finger
energy in him but he also loves his family and he
does actually genuinely care about Rhaenyra so
that's why he asks viserys later genuinely for
her hand in marriage like let me marry her and
we will restore the house of the Dragon he also
said the name of the show in the show he did the
thing again so did the series later in the episode
two people in the episode said it he wants to take
their family back to a more biblical era in their
history back to what their family used to be like
during the time of aegon the Conqueror which is
why I think he stopped things before they went
too far here like they have a little bit of fun
but he's like okay no no like we can't we can't
do this we have to do it officially otherwise
things are going to get really really nasty in
the realm and that's why I think that Mysteria
who they call the White Worm later in the episode
actually informs on him to Otto Hightower because
he's trying to protect the realm and protect him
from himself kind of like Varys did during the
original Game of Thrones series where he said I'm
a servant of the realm I want to help the realm
which is why I think a Targaryen restoration will
help the realm and why I'm helping Daenerys and I
think maseria probably thought that if Daemon were
to actually marry rhaenyra it would only cause an
even greater Civil War it would split the realm
which is ironic because that winds up happening
anyway the whole idea that right now half the
realm thinks that aegon II should be on the
Iron Throne the other half thinks that Rhaenyra
should but if right now renira married Daemon then
that would get even worse like I said it's ironic
because this is building towards the actual Dance
of the Dragons where that very literal thing
happens you could also draw a connection back
to episode 2 I believe it was where Corliss said
to viserys you should never try to await a storm
always sail around it or into it you can think of
the storm as being the dance of the Dragons but
also being Rhaenyra and Daemon together then they
pay off that huge Twist on the long-running Harwin
strong rumor with the Criston Cole and Rhaenyra
scene they wind up getting it on and at the end
of the episode where the grand maester brings her
the moon tea you don't see her actually take it
so you're like wait a minute did she take it did
she not take it does this mean that her first son
jacaris who's born the year after this episode
is actually Criston Cole's son instead of being
horlin strong son so that's what I mean when they
say they pay off the big Harwin strong rumor with
a Twist because it's not Harwin strong it might
actually be Criston Coulson you can let me know
in the comments if you actually believe that
do you actually think that she's pregnant at
the end of the episode and did not take the moon T
everybody's going to be on belly watch after next
week's episode like how much time goes by and how
quickly does she give birth then when they have
the scene of Otto throwing Daemon under the bus
like I said the White Worm is a reference to miss
area and two Daemon's credit viserys immediately
thinks that Otto is lying to him there's been a
lot of people during this series so far that have
suspected that he's been playing this long con to
position his family closer to the Iron Throne
through an heir through aegon II now the way
the showrunners talk about the character the way
that Rhys Ifans talks about Otto Hightower the
character he plays is that he tries to do what
he thinks is best for the realm but there's the
question of his judgment like is this better for
the realm or is this better just for your family
like is this just advantageous to your family
feel kind of bad for Alicent Hightower too because
viserys kind of throws her under the bus too like
oh you clearly threw her at me I knew what's going
on this whole time now it just took me a little
while to figure it out I think part of the idea
too by the end of the episode is that alicent also
kind of feels that same energy too like she feels
as if she's been thrown at viserys and nobody
really cares about actual her like they just
use her as a tool you notice the day after that
rhaenyra and Criston Cole do the deed even though
she's trying to be kind of cute with him she's
not wearing Daemon's necklace anymore because
she kind of hates him right now and then when she
has the conversation with alicent the reason why
alicent is like so against her being with Daemon
because that's pretty normal for their family
like why would she be so against it is because
she's disgusted by the idea of the targaryen's
practice of sister wiping just in general and the
reason why is because she's this hugely devout
person of the faith of the seven you notice in
all the trailers she's wearing the seven pointed
star necklace around her neck the whole idea
with the hightowers is they come from old town
but before King's Landing existed before aegon's
Conquest the great sept in the high septon were
down in Old Town so the high Towers had a strong
connection with the faith for thousands of years
so that's why she comes off as being such a goody
goody girl and the whole idea is the faith of the
seven absolutely hated aegon the Conqueror and his
sister wiving and all the other sister wiving that
happened later in their family in fact jahiris
Targaryen who they reference a couple times in
the episode actually had to drop a legal document
and legalize the practice of the Targaryen Sister
Wives so that the faith wouldn't start another
war with them so because alicent is such a devout
follower of the faith and they hate sister wiping
that's why alicent hates sister wiving so much
and when Daemon gets hauled in and raked over the
coals by visares the reason why he doesn't try to
deny the allegations is because he actually does
want to marry renyra so he's like who cares what
does it matter so like he's actually asking him
here like Let Us return the house of the Dragon
saying the name of the show in the show again to
its former glory and even though they didn't make
it very clear in the episode viserys is very
against renyra marrying Daemon like he doesn't
want them to get together at all not because
he hates Daemon just because he doesn't want
to see that happen like he doesn't like the idea
of a sister wiving their family so much and just
for reference Daemon and visera's parents which
they mentioned a couple times in the episode they
reference their mother and they referenced their
father Balon Targaryen Balon the brave they were
actually brother and sister so they were even more
closely related than viserys his wife who was his
cousin basically Daemon and Rhaenyra are getting
together is kind of like Jon Snow and Daenerys
getting together like the aunt getting together
with the nephew only this time it's flipped is
the older Uncle getting together with the younger
niece you also notice Daemon keeps trying to slide
by on technicalities like aegon the Conqueror
had two wives why don't you let me have two wives
then viserys gives Rhaenyra another cool history
lesson in front of his giant model of the Valyrian
Freehold when he heats up the Valyrian dagger he
explains the aegons of Valyrian pyromancers are
the ones who etched the prophecy of A Song of
Ice and Fire on at the prophecy of the prince
of his promise which is a Jon Snow reference
you could also call it a Daenerys reference
too because in High Valyrian there's no word to
distinguish between prince and princess like the
word for Prince is the same word as Princess he
also says the blade belonged to Anar Targaryen
before aegon aener was his ancestor who sailed the
entire Targaryen family took their Holdings from
valyria to Dragonstone after danis the dreamer his
daughter had the vision of the Doom that was about
seven generations before aegon the Conqueror was
born and then he's is hard to know who the dagger
belonged to before aenar Targaryen just claiming
that the dagger itself is much much older than we
believe but it does confirm my theory that aegon
the Conqueror just inscribed the prophecy on the
dagger like the dagger already existed and he
just modified it a little bit the reason he
also shows the prophecy again is to remind her
about her obligation to guard against the long
night the white walkers the night King I already
explained the jahiris reference here when he
talks about disinheriting her the daughter that
jaeherys had that he did wind up disinheriting
during the episode when she talks to Daemon about
bastards and just doing whatever you want and then
to visiris about the same thing basically like
you can do whatever you want that's also them
referencing viserys's bastard whose name Tristan
truefire he then decides to solve all their
problems by having her marry laenor velaryon like
all the problems just in general but she agrees
only on the condition that he basically get rid
of Otto Hightower is hand to the king when he's
talking to Otto Hightower in the room of the
small Council he talks about the circumstances
of his father balon's death his father died very
suddenly after complaining of a stitch in his side
while on a hunting trip which is also meant to be
a bit of a reference to the events of episode 3
when they were on the hunt and what happened to
Robert Baratheon dying after going on a hunting
trip of his own so if you actually have a shot
of sitting on a throne somewhere wearing a crown
do not go on any hunting trips anytime soon
he also references that his father Balon Road
Veigar the biggest dragon that's alive in the
timeline right now that's important for later
so just remember that he mentioned Veigar I think
we'll see her in next week's episode but at least
by the episode after that they've been teasing
vegar for like the last couple of episodes and
when he says his father's belly burst I think
the reason his father died was probably from a
burst appendix and then obviously at the end of
the episode they end with that big wtfm where
the grand maester brings Rhaenyra the moon T but
you don't see her take it so you're like wait a
minute if her first child is going to be born
like a year after the events of this episode
does that mean that her child really belongs to
Criston Cole things just got way spicier post all
your theories about that in the comments below
did she actually take the moon tea like is she
pregnant at the beginning of next week's episode
if you spotted any of their big Easter eggs or
references in the episode that I didn't talk about
in the video just write them Below in the comments
my episode 5 trailer video will post next in
my full episode 5 video will post next week
after they release it everyone click here for
my house of the Dragon episode 5 trailer video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!